this is just asking questions a show for
inquiring minds on
[Music]
reason welcome to the inaugural episode
of just asking questions which is also
our first in-person episode since my
co-host Liz wolf and I live about 800
miles away and we are pleased to welcome
as our very first guest podcaster
extraordinaire Dave Smith Dave thanks
for joining us oh thank you for having
me I'm honored to be uh on the first
episode well we wanted to have you on
the first episode because it kind of
sets the tone for what we want to do
which is to engage people who are like I
don't know 70 80% in agreement with us
but then also explore that that's like I
feel like that's a good starting place
where we have enough Common Ground where
we don't have to quibble about like the
the biggest picture questions but we can
really get down into the details about
about some of the finer points so uh
we're we're very grateful to have you
here today oh my pleasure so for our
first question I want to open this up to
everybody but we will obviously give our
guest of honor the chance to answer
first what is a Libertarian what beliefs
are disqualifying for Libertarians to
hold today yeah I well I would say to me
libertarianism is the belief in self-
ownership private property rights and
the non-aggression principle to me I
think that's the best philosophically
sound definition of it that isn't
circular you know what I mean that it's
not just like a definition like well
someone who believes in Freedom or you
know maximum Freedom or something like
that uh so a Libertarian would be
someone to me who believes in that um
and I I would argue that almost everyone
who calls themselves a Libertarian
whether they would agree with my
definition or not whenever they're
arguing for a Libertarian position it's
completely consistent with all of that
now what beliefs are disqualifying to
you is tough to quibble about because I
don't know look like Gary Johnson um
wanted to legalize pot but not any other
drugs or not any harder drugs please
explain to me how you think that
legalizing marijuana straight through to
heroin can possibly be a harm reduction
Forum it makes no sense to me we are not
espousing the legalization of any drugs
outside of marijuana I'm not going to
say he's not a Libertarian um but I
would say he's not a Libertarian on
heroin if that makes sense right like
that's just it's completely contradicts
what Libertarians believe so I don't
know exactly I probably there are
probably some issues for me that he
seemed pretty blissed out like he might
have been on heroin who's to say yeah no
I think it's just a lot of edibles but I
don't I don't know for sure um but so I
don't know you know everybody says like
you're not a real libertarian to every
other libertarian so I try to just not
get involved in that although I will say
there are certain things probably you
know like to me War and Peace is the
biggest issue and people who support
support Wars I really do not consider
them Libertarians I just think that it's
like if you are for freedom and against
the government there is no worst
government policy in the world than War
there's not even a close second and uh
that you know that's you know tends to
violate more freedom than any other
policy where do you encounter those
Libertarians though um well where are
the pro proar Libertarians where are
they hiding well I mean if you if you
want to listen to uh you know Ted
Carpenter who just left uh KO gave like
a 45 minute speech on this of how much
there is in some of these like you know
uh libertarian uh you know organizations
um I just had a debate with um the
Austin Peterson who was was a LP
candidate for president uh years ago um
yeah I mean I think they're out there
certainly during the um during the
Ukraine war there were a lot of people
um who cons call themselves libertarian
who were very quick to say you're a you
know a Putin propagandist if for for
bringing up you know the fact that us
you know giving a blank check to this
war has done nothing but kill hundreds
of thousands of people so they're they
exist but there can be Wars that
Libertarians would support yes would you
agree with that okay just not any in
modern yeah no like yeah I think um the
American Revolutionary War would be a
legit yes if you're invaded by an army
you have a right to violently try to get
them out um that's but not too many of
those not too many of those recently
yeah I mean that that's where it starts
to you put the non-aggression principle
at the center of libertarianism and
that's where it starts to get a little
murky for me because I think that there
would be legitimate Wars of self-defense
but how would you square that ever with
the non-aggression a PR principle
because there are always going to
be casualties that you know um
collateral damage well I mean if you're
uh if if there's an invading Army I
think that by definition they are the
aggressive and then yeah I think it's
reasonable like if you're saying am I
going to split hairs down to the point
that like this other soldier in that uh
you know uniform hasn't fired a shot yet
so is he I would say yes he's fair game
you rolled in with an invading gang
you've you've you know uh given up your
rights me the non-aggression principle
doesn't mean you seed your right to
self-defense right like but that can
sometimes depending on the specific
situation that can be really difficult
to sus out in the moment well with the
Ukraine Russia War for instance the
libertarian type people who were siding
with Ukraine in that war saw Ukraine as
repelling an Invader uh I presume your
objection to that is more so America's
involvement not necessarily the
ukrainians right oh no I mean I think to
be clear I think the ukrainians have a
right to self-defense and they have a
right to stay and fight um for their
territory if that's what they wish to do
um but that's there's a lot more to that
picture than that's just what's going
going on and yeah like my problem was
not just my problem was American
involvement and NATO's involvement going
way back for for decades that you know
this intentional policy of like trying
to to needle the Russians over and over
again and then finally being like
surprised when it IT resulted in this um
but I would say that you know there's
like so this is removed from any moral
feeling about this ukrainians have a
right to defend themselves but you also
like if someone pulls a gun on you and
ask for your wallet you have a right to
fist fight that guy it's not necessarily
a good idea and so I've that's more been
my thing with Ukraine it's like you're
fighting a fight you can't possibly win
this was you know like this was
blasphemy to say this for the last
couple years but now everybody's come
around to acknowledge that even with the
blank check from America over these two
years they just have no shot of winning
so now we're right back to negotiating
time and uh and yeah I'd be against you
know Americans being forced to fund a
war which both armies are being forced
to fight um because these are two
conscripted armies after all so that's
um there's nothing libertarian about
that I think that with one real Mark
where it starts to complicated here for
me is
that the when you're talking about what
is the role of America's military and I
think that you and I share a sort of
libertarian Genesis in that we were I
became a libertarian a few years before
Ron Paul made his run but the Ron Paul's
2008 run was certainly energizing for me
and what really got me deep into
libertarianism and um that you know it
it was the first time I'd heard about
the concept of blowback and so forth and
so it was it was very formative for me
as I know it was for you however um
there are times
when it it seems as if
Liber some
Libertarians they almost their analysis
is almost which side uh is America not
funding and that is the side that's
who's who who we are going to back um
and
so I I I see um in in the Ukraine Russia
War um there
is some some of America's self there
there is a self-interest for America's
defense
to make it costly to Russia to invade um
and say you know you can't uh that that
you know some some level of stability
and not um you know escalating things
towards uh or you know not giving a
blank check for you to just March troops
over borders is there not something to
that like Can it can self-interest
expand Beyond simply only if you are
literally you know there's bombs on your
soil can you offer any support
whatsoever well I
mean so in a way like if that's the the
thinking which I do think is the
thinking in DC at least for the most for
the most part um it's like there's a few
things to that number one um so that if
if you know putting some type of penalty
on Russia for invading is in America's
interest well let's just be really
brutally honest well the cost of that is
hundreds of thousand of Ukrainian lives
so all right that's if that's a cost
you're like comfortable paying fine but
like maybe take that Ukraine flag out of
your Twitter bio because like you're
really the most anti- Ukraine person um
but then again these Grand plans like
yeah maybe it would have been in
America's best interest if democracy had
swept the region in the Middle East and
then they were all like Jeffersonian
Republicans or something like that but
that plan doesn't seem to be working out
too well and all that it seems like I
mean I think that um you know like the
the US dollar is the reserved standard
of the world is probably in more
Jeopardy right now than at any point in
my lifetime this has driven Russia and
China to be much closer allies you've
seen um kind of like a real almost
almost a real crack to the unipolar
world where it's not even clear that we
really are in a unipol unipolar world
anymore so I would say that look my
perspective from the Russia thing is
that obviously Vladimir Putin is he's
wrong to invade and it's been the war
has been horrific um I do think that
that not living in libertarian Universe
living in the real world and trying to
have some type of reasonable modern
expectations for what governments are
going to do that the idea that Vladimir
Putin said for years you cannot expand
your military Alliance to Ukraine that
is off the table that is my red line and
they knew this I mean there's that great
uh memo if you've never read it the net
means net where the current CIA director
privately writes to cond a rice and is
like listen this is for real this is
their Red Line you can't and there is
just no way America would tolerate that
I mean can you imagine if like if if
Russia was like we're bringing Mexico
into our military Alliance what do you
think the reaction from Washington DC
would be' be like absolutely you are not
and we would send troops in there in a
second if that was the plan and they
right in his face kept telling him well
yes we are yes we are we're going to do
it they announced at the Bucharest uh
Summit in in 2008 just before the war
broke out uh c r sorry that's racist uh
Camala Harris uh was over there saying
uh Cala Harris was over there saying
we're still bringing nato in it's still
the plan and so I just think like there
is no powerful country that would
possibly have reacted different to this
so I don't you know that doesn't mean
it's good or it's right but my takeaway
from that is like why would we be so
stupid as to keep doing this for no
benefit other than like world domination
yeah and um I think that you know
pushing pushing NATO further and further
in is certainly uh an escalating move
and I agree with you there I guess the
the the W the the bigger like
philosophical question I'm trying to get
to is like so looking at uh as an
example looking at what just happened in
Israel um what did the US do the US sent
in our one of our largest aircraft
carriers into the Mediterranean to
prevent vent all these other players
from getting involved and I mean the
idea is to stop this from escalating
into a regional war that would seem to
me to be in America's self-interest to
stop that escalation and it's a
relatively low cost of like we're just
going to park this carrier here would
that fall within your definition of the
conforming to the non-aggression
principle well I mean no not really and
certainly it's you know I'm a complete
non-interventionist on all this stuff so
I don't support that it's not like the
most egregious thing the the American
military's ever done like I'm kind of on
the scale of things to be outraged by
but look that's just like you're looking
at one tiny little element of this huge
conflict and being like well look this
one thing here was done you know to that
could prevent a wider War but the whole
thing only exists because the US has
been propping up this this status quo
for for 60 years and the fact that we
think we're going to maintain this thing
where we go okay well here's what we're
going to do we're going to um prop up
Israel we're going to you know make it
so that the entire Global Community
which has been outraged about the
treatment of Palestinians for since
1967 um that we're going to whatever you
know we'll veto everything at the UN
we'll ignore all of these Global human
rights organizations we're going to prop
up dictators in Egypt and Saudi Arabia
and we're like that we're going to
maintain this whole thing and then when
it blows up the takeaway to me isn't
like well you know we do have to like
you know sometimes prevent these wars
from happening the truth is that this um
none of none of any of this should be
America's business and if we're going to
get in you know if you believe and this
is what like Ted Carpenter said in that
whole speech about uh where he was
blasting KO um that it's like look the
idea if you're anything that considers
yourself a Libertarian or your 70% of
agree with me or whatever the that
doesn't come with being the world Empire
you don't have there is no such thing as
a restrained uh a constrained
constitutional republic that is also the
Empire of the world war is the health of
the state War always grows uh government
for other purposes other than just the
war and people always lose the most of
their civil liberty the the CI civil
liberties are lost the most during times
of War I want to get back on track a
little bit but I do think that there's U
you know these are themes that we were
talking on touching on in a recent
stream where we interviewed Russ Roberts
who I think comes at this issue from a
very different perspective than you do
but the thing that I wish more
Libertarians would grapple with is there
is a difference between the aspiration
of the role America plays and figuring
out from where we currently are what is
the appropriate approach to get to where
we want to be um because we I think we
can all recognize that like the US has
been funding Israel and supporting
Israel for a very very long time and I
think many people many good Libertarians
would say Hey you know it's long past
time to uh cut Israel off and allow them
to really stand on their own two feet
they have the ability to do that but
realistically that's not something that
we can do right now like we can't just
fully cut off funding right now and
expect there to be no awful
ramifications that would stem from that
so the thing that I always struggle with
with the vision that you're articulating
is okay but how do you get from point A
to point B well I don't know I I think
I'd kind of reject the assumption that
it would be some type of disaster if we
were to cut off uh Aid to Israel right
now I mean this is kind of the same like
thinking yeah I mean look it would put
enormous pressure on them to negotiate
that that's really what they'd have to
do look Israel is not it this isn't 1948
Israel isn't in a a state of war with
all the Arab surrounding Nations which
is a precise argument that many people
make for why we should have at some
point between 1948 and you know last
year chosen to begin to sort of cut them
off from us funding and support right
like there but but then there's a
certain symbolic like if we do that
right now surely that does have
ramifications Beyond you know what they
would have been had we done that in 2019
well I no I agree it has ramifications
but I'm just saying that like they might
be very positive um like uh there's look
Israel has has been at peace with Egypt
since the 1970s they're at peace with
Jordan they're at peace with uh Saudi
Arabia all of the the they they bomb
Syria constantly they've NE Syria's
never response to them they're just
allowed to it's not even like an issue
um Iran might funnel some money to Hamas
maybe some to uh I'm sorry to Hezbollah
and and some to Hamas um that's it's not
is it Israel if they didn't have the
backing of the United States of America
would be heavily incentivized to
actually deal with the Palestinians to
actually work out a real peace process
not this pretend one to grant them their
independence stop occupying their areas
because they look a lot of these things
right like with zalinski and now with
Netanyahu part of why they're so willing
to be so um provocative is because they
know they have the baddest bully in the
world that has their back and if they
didn't they might be like okay well look
we really got to think about this maybe
we shouldn't just bomb the hell out of
Gaza right now because that might
actually piss off the world you know and
so like the we there's this tremendous
moral hazard that we create when we as
the strongest country in the history of
the world are like we have your back you
know yeah and I I have to say that I I
agree with
you in the to the degree that when I see
these images you know uh Israel is
having they're making very tough moral
choices right now and they're making
choices that I don't always agree with
and to have us funding or you know being
perceived to be joined at the hip with
every bomb that they're dropping is is a
very bad situation so I would like to
see us get disentangled on the other
hand I think that at the moment they
have moral they have some
moral um basically they have my moral
support in terms of pursuing Hamas and
doing everything they can that's not a
war crime to root out Hamas to the
degree that that's possible so I I think
that to some
degree if the the less entangled that
the US got with
Israel the more aggressive we might
actually see Israel get in in some in
some way uh and that's something that we
might have to get comfortable with if we
seriously want
to disentangle with our allies I don't I
I I don't think there's reason to
believe that Israel is going to really
take the gloves off if America stops
backing them I think it would be much
more reasonable that they would you know
uh that they would be more concerned
coming from a slightly more vulnerable
position um but you know look Israel
Israel won a War in 1967 and they've
been holding these people ever since and
they just don't have a right to do that
you mean the West Bank the West Bank and
Gaza um there's that that's when they
took control of of all of Palestine yeah
but it is worth noting also that the
situation in Gaza has changed in the
last you know 16 17 years oh for sure
but I'm just saying Gaza situation is
quite different than the West Bank one
yes absolutely but I'm just saying like
they won a War in 1967 they have
literally not granted these people their
independent and since then they then
okay if you want to talk about what's
happened over the last 15 years or so
they then went on a stated intentional
they took on a an intentional goal of
supporting Hamas specifically so that
they could never get their independence
so they could never get their state and
you can read it all you know Scott
Horton and uh um and Connor every time
you mention Scott Horton on the show we
all have to take a drink you know okay F
well look I'm just saying they have a
great piece up at antiwar.com and you
can just it's like read them and weep
these are the in their own words
Benjamin Netanyahu and all types of top
government level people saying this is
our plan and for this reason we are
going to support Hamas because no one
will ever grant them statehood as long
as Hamas is in control but Hamas has
agency in this too right of course of
course but I'm just saying yeah of
course nyaho also like these actions are
not like widely supported by the Israeli
people like this I'm yes these are
governments this is a Hamas is a
criminal gang is governments and up in a
million ways I totally I'm just saying
like coming at it from the point of view
of being like Oh well listen I do kind
of root for them and they do have the
moral right to do this it's like yeah
but we're talking about the guys who had
a an a intentional policy of propping up
this this uh terrorist organization to
use them so that they could never Grant
the Palestinian people who just like the
Israelis are separate from their
government so that they could never
Grant those people their own
independence and autonomy and then it
blew up in their face and now they're
like freaking carpet but all right I
don't people don't like that term but
they are do you have you looked like the
numbers like they've dropped more bombs
than we did in a year in Afghanistan on
Gaza over a few weeks and so no I don't
look at that situation and go like oh
well they do have like the moral right
to root these people out it's like yes
like the people who did October 7th all
deserve to die okay but I'm sorry when
your plan was to prop up a terrorist
organization so that the people in
Palestine never get their autonomy and
then you use that as an excuse to then
just start but it wasn't by propping up
a terrorist organization in a in a
vacuum right like there were multiple
competing factions of you know
Palestinian groups that were all going
to create a worse situation for Israel
and so to some degree this was like a
strategic choice to Pi to pick the
craziest of them that not but it's not
like they were picking between like
there's one terrorist group and then
there's two democracy loving you know
groups that will really take care of the
people and like yeah we're really going
to like go for the terrorists and for
them right like it's not the choice was
the palan author how bad of a choice it
was okay but the choice was between say
like uh the PLO say like uh arhats
Arafat types who are literally saying
are standing there saying we reject
terrorism we don't want to do that
anymore we want to come to the table
we'll accept 67 borders we'll accept 22%
instead of the
44% that the UN partition plan even
recommended which that was BS because
there was no reason they should have
taken so little they're saying we'll
take the 22% we want peace we now I'm
not they said this I'm not saying
they're perfect angels but to choose
between that and Hamas and to choose
Hamas over that option that this isn't
like oh we have a bunch of bad options
and so we got to pick one this is like
we have clearly better options and we
will pick the craziest one so that they
look crazy to the world it's frankly the
exact same behavior as American voters
right like there's the craziest
[__] theory of governance I
think that this was like a was it
originally like a Massie proposal and
it's like sometimes people simply want
to vote for the craziest [__] in
the room like that to somee explains a
little bit of the Trump phenomenon I do
want to um stifle some of my greatest sh
thoughts and move us back in the
direction of actually answering what
libertarianism because I think we have
established that Libertarians aren't
generally warhawks um and we are not
generally hosels or even sists uh Zach
how do you look at this question of what
is a Libertarian defining yourself
either in terms totally independent of
Daves or perhaps in response to Daves
yeah there there's a lot of overlap
unsurprisingly I see Libertarians as
extreme Skeptics of state power and the
reason for that is that we are against
violent monopolies and for voluntary
Association to the degree that that's
possible and that is because self-
ownership we believe in that idea that
uh self- ownership self-authorship you
control your own destiny you write your
own story and um you know the way I like
to think of it is this this phrase right
to try like you have should have the
right to challenge monopolies and that
is something Li I think Libertarians
across the board recognize that the
state is a monopoly on violence and they
use that Monopoly to create other
monopolies like we've got Elizabeth
Warren and the like out there always
talking about monopolies I think she was
just tweeting about a sandwich shop
Monopoly that she's going to break up
but the real monopolies are created by
governments and um I think that for
various we all have uh I think where
where the diff the differences come in
is that we have different reasons for
thinking that monopolies are are bad but
um my reason for thinking monopolies are
bad is because um I believe that the
experimentation um and competition
creates progress and prosperity so
that's my I like that a lot I think I
agree with both of the things that you
guys said and my definition is perhaps
even simpler this idea that Libertarians
don't look to the government to fix what
ails us I think Libertarians ought to
have and generally do have a high degree
of comfort with voluntary action
existing in Civil Society outside from
government Libertarians I think
frequently gravitate toward voice but
also I love the strain of Libertarians
that gravitate toward exit
trying to exist outside of governments
you know I look at people living off the
grid uh people choosing to homeschool
there are so many ways that people can
just kind of prove out the idea that we
actually don't need the government to
take care of us in a gazillion ways we
sometimes Prosper far far far outside of
the purview of the state and in fact
people can be so much Freer to live
better lives that way um you know
obviously like the non-aggression
principle is you know pretty to all of
this uh but I think Libertarians
dispositionally also tend to just be
people who take incentives seriously and
second order impacts consequ like
unintended consequences um and I really
appreciate how Libertarians are so
frequently asking this question of
government policies well what are the
Alternatives or what are bad incentives
that could possibly be created by this I
love how Libertarians focus on tradeoffs
and it drives me absolutely insane that
so much of the left and the right seem
to you know never entertain the
possibility that a government policy
could actually lead to Awful unintended
consequences what do you think Dave does
any of those do you jive with any of
those or disagreements yeah I mean I
pretty much agree with what what you
guys are saying I mean like I the the
definition I give I think is like kind
of to the core of the philosophical
belief but I I agree with everything
both of you guys said and I I just think
that the to me the fun the fundamental
libertarian Insight is that um what the
government is is as you said a monopoly
on violence I don't even know if that's
the perfect way to say it it's like it's
because there are other violent people
right so there's like there's criminals
too so it's not like they have what they
have is they have a monopoly on the
legal uh legal initiation of violence
right so like they can do it legally but
that I think if you just look at things
philosophically like because this is
what I agree with all the
consequentialist stuff too like I think
it's it's pretty obvious like you could
look at uh South Korea and North Korea
and be like okay what works to create
Prosperity here it's not uh central
control um but you mean it's not pkin
grocery stores it's all fake fruit like
turns out um but uh there's to me it's
like if you believe in Morality at all
which almost everybody does and there
are some people who just reject it
entirely but almost everyone in the
political realm like if you listen to
Bernie Sanders he'll say it's it's uh
it's immoral that there's this income
inequality and you you listen quite
clear where they're getting it from but
they do have some
sort but if you believe there is such
thing as right and wrong then I would
say inherently that has to be like
morality has to transcend what human
beings what organizations we create so
like in other words like if you think
like if you think uh murder is wrong and
you you were on a desert island or some
you know uninhabited land and there's no
government and there's no rules and
someone murdered somebody that would be
just as morally wrong there as it is
here there just doesn't happen to be a
legal system or police or whatever um
but the morality of It kind of has to be
the same otherwise we're not really
talking about morality and so look if
any other group of people did what the
government does we would know what to
call it right away you would just be
like oh this is the mafia or this is a
criminal or this is you know like
taxation what is theft you're just
forcing someone to give you their money
um you know Wars or mass murder
campaigns like all of this stuff if you
if anybody else any other group of
people decided like we deem ourselves
The Regulators and we're going to go
around and start regulating these
businesses you'd be like Oh no you're a
gang like you're a criminal organization
and so if you believe in Morality I
think it has to be the same whether
government does it or not and that
voting doesn't somehow change the moral
characteristics of what a group of
people do right the the issue that I
have with being too moralistic about it
though is that we don't know if the
absence of this you know legitimate
Monopoly on violence is a stable
situation like it's something that is
yet to be seen I'm I'm open to the
possibility that uh everything could be
privatized one day or something but um I
you know it it's got to be that's why I
favor the this definition where it's a
little bit more um experimental and
you're saying let's try to do not have
the state do this thing that we're all
used to the state doing okay fair enough
and I'm not even like I don't want to
you know do like a whole Anarchy vers
minarchy like thing because I just in
today's day and age it's like seems so
crazy because we're so far from both um
but like so then what is the if you're
like completely against monopolies and
you recognize that monopolies like just
lead to these terrible results so why is
it that it's just like whatever these
like five most crucial of things like
why is is it just like writing laws in
courts and police and military or things
like that have to be run by a monopoly
like why is it because it seems to me
like if we're saying that monopolies
especially violent monopolies are really
bad at producing things then why would
it be like they're really bad at
producing things in every other field
but the most important things must be
run in the worst way to produce things
otherwise we'd all be live in a dystopia
yeah I'm I'm not really sure all I can
say is that it's not that I I like I
like the theory but I like the theory to
be bolstered by the empirical reality so
I like to see it play out and kind of
proceed with caution because kind of
what the the situation that you see when
there's an absence of a state is often
it's creates a power vacuum and then
something worse comes in and so is that
a stable situation I mean I'm I'm
interested in the experiments that are
happening along these lines you know I
did documentary about this place called
prospera in uh Honduras where they're
trying to privatize all the services I
think maybe maybe at a very small like
micro scale like that it can work and
prove itself out um it's just you know
the like you said the practicality of
even really discussing it at at a larger
level doesn't doesn't even lead anywhere
I think the answer is a little bit
different I like what you're saying uh
and you surely will not find this to be
satisfactory or something particularly
Earth shattering but I do believe in a
little bit of the um sort of unique
power of the US Constitution and some of
the um structures outlined in it that I
think you know many a liberal who did
their sort of um Trump hysteria oped
piece and acted like American democracy
was horribly imperiled during the Trump
years uh don't Place very much faith in
our Constitution and don't Place very
much faith in our court systems or in
federalism or in the abilities of this
very complex system of checks and
balances to actually serve as um
something that prevents you know the
worst excesses of executive overreach
and I think we're Libertarians right
like there are lots of things that we
could sit here and point to and say well
you know executive overreach
specifically when it comes to war making
Powers okay that's something we
absolutely oppose and so surely the
Constitution has failed Us in X Y and Z
ways however with that massive caveat I
do think constitutional limits have done
a pretty good job of ensuring some of
these State institutions have actually
done a decent but imperfect job of
serving their intended function uh and I
I Look to that as something that like
the American system has that many other
systems don't and as sort of the best
possible argument for um the more
limited government libertarian view
versus The ancap View well I mean if you
want to look at how well and I'm not
saying there like there are examples
here where like you know some
unconstitutional policy has been struck
down you know what I mean or things like
that but if you want to zoom out and
just look at how good the Constitution
has done at limiting government
I mean we're the biggest government in
the history of the world and by far and
the biggest organization in the history
of the world is the US federal
government by any metric um and so I'm
not saying I'm not arguing that this is
a compelling argument to you yeah no I'm
I'm just saying any like like that you
guys were talking about how like it was
the Ron Paul era that sort of you know
radicalized um you guys and sort of
brought you to the libertarian cause for
me it was the Snowden Revelations um
because I'm about a decade younger than
you guys um in case it's not obvious
yeah rub it in
fewer children fewer wrinkles a decade
younger but no it was it was the Snowden
Revelations that really um were the
thing I was already pretty libertarian
adjacent was sort of like a little bit
of oh I kind of dislike liberal policies
and I'm more into interested in
conservative policies but hey the drug
war is really bad and then it was the
Snowden stuff that really drove home
this idea of like holy [__] like the
government has just been spying on its
citizens and none of us were really
aware of this and it began to make me
pretty radicalized and interested in
Fourth Amendment issues and also pretty
passionate about the cause of like we
need to ensure that whistleblowers have
these first amendment protections to be
able to um you know they'll still
frequently get tried for treason or have
to flee the country but whistle blowing
is a really important Public Service um
and I think that spoke a little bit to
this like you know appreciation for
dissidents but also an appreciation for
what we were able to learn and how we
were able to become empowered with more
knowledge of how our government was
spying on us and lying about it yeah and
that that's
the so I con seeed that like yeah but
the the the the flip side of that the
fact that we are able to get that
knowledge out there is why I chafe a
little bit at what the way you're
characterizing it Dave because um just
saying that um you know it's the biggest
government in history doesn't really
capture the fact that this is not the
most tyrannical government in history is
CER also how are you even character like
how how are you even deciding that right
like isn't the CCP arguably like way
bigger in terms of like bureaucratic
function I mean and number of employees
and I mean you got maybe someone could
Google it real quick but I would bet we
have more federal employees in in DC
than they have that that I don't know
for sure but look in terms of how much
money it spends um how many bases it has
abroad vers how many I mean I think it
would be it would dwarf uh now to your
point North Korea is a much smaller
government than us but yeah they're much
worse to their own people however again
you got to look at this thing totality
if you're going to judge governments you
know you don't judge them by how they
treat the best of their people you kind
of you know like in the same way if you
were judging like a slave master and he
had like 20 slaves who he just like
viciously beat every day but then he had
another 10 that lived in the house who
he treated pretty good we don't go like
you know you're judging him off of the
worst of what he does and so if you're
going to judge America you can't just
judge America based on like hey it's
kind of nice to live in Brooklyn you
know what I mean like you got to judge
it on on Iraq Afghanistan Syria Libya
Somalia
you know what I mean like this is we've
we have killed millions of innocent
people just in the last 20 years I'm not
even going to go back to like Vietnam
and all of this living in Brooklyn isn't
nice I don't know what you're talking
about there it was nice it was nice at
that point I don't know it was really
cool in the ' 80s and 90s by the way
this this is you know the this is this
is foreign policy where
we have a lot of agreement but
domestically it's you know living in
America is not
living under tyranny uh and by
historical standards yeah it's it's all
like variations yes but I agree with you
I'm not I'm not trying to paint a
picture like oh you have a worse life
here than you would living in any one of
you know like any like Muslim country or
living in China or anything like that I
mean China there's probably like there
are probably some people who have very
good lives uh in China but you don't
really want to live like the average
person uh does over there so I'm not
denying that but I'm just saying if
you're going to look at uh the American
government you kind of have to look at
it in its totality and judge it by the
worst like we don't judge the Soviet
Union based off what like some guy who
was like connected to the government who
lived really well you know what I mean
like and there were people like that we
judge them by what they did to the
ukrainians right because because America
has a flawed foreign policy to say the
least that does not justify throwing out
all of the Constitutional protections
all the pr Liberty aspects of the US
government and saying we're going to
throw the baby out with the bath water
that is where I think you know we butt
heads a little bit with your Camp name
name another country that has a better
system of federalism a better system of
checks on executive power better speech
protections like like name name the
country that is hitting a lot of these
categories consistently much more than
we are that is operating at scale my
friend well listen Maybe that's maybe
the goal should be a thousand Lenin you
that's said I think but but no take it
take it a little more seriously than
that right like
Lenin isn't a good enough answer for me
well I mean look there's there's
positive qualities that different
different countries have I don't know if
you're going to go to court in any
country which country do you want to be
doing that in if you're you know being
tried for a crime it depends what you're
being tried for I mean it's like it
depends on on the situation you know I I
don't think that um there's there's
probably lots of countries even more
primitively corrupt countries where you
would probably be better off in certain
in certain situations I mean like you
know there's there's a Eastern European
countries where you could just pay a cop
off when they stop you now that we may
look down at that like oh that's so
corrupt but believe me if you're if
you're carrying around like weed in
Texas or something like that you'd wish
you could pay that cop off I have in
fact been in the situation of carrying
around weed in Texas and getting into
some uh sticky uh terrain there but I do
think there's this interesting question
of like not just like criminal offenses
but also like civil court like what
about like enforcement of contracts and
ensuring that you get a fair shake and
the ability to resolve disputes I I I
just think it is important to give the
us a little bit you know I hate to say
but to give the state a little bit more
credit for the things that we are we
have actually very consistently for the
last 300 years done pretty well let me
pick up on the the Thousand licked and
shines point because it that this is
essentially the strategy of the mises
caucus that took over the libertarian
party um and their their
decentralization project
decentralization we talked to Michael
Heist about it um I want to we're going
to play a clip because Nick interviewed
you and Reno during the caucus takeover
of the libertarian party in May
2022 and he asked you what you want to
see the lp doing in the Years leading up
to the 2024 election which we now
rapidly approaching and this is what you
said I think resparking the Ron Paul
Revolution I think that's the the task
right in front of us I think if we're
ever going to be like if we're ever
going to get to a to be a more free
Society we need to have a lot more
people who desire a free Society I don't
think there's any path there without
that and the only way to do that is to
inspire a lot of enthusiasm and energy
and particularly amongst young people
because I think if we're playing the
long game here that's what matters the
most and the only way to do that is to
actually stand for something and really
introduce people to a radical new way of
thinking about things you know you don't
do that by running Bill Weld and saying
hey this is the most boring moderate
establishment guy we could find to call
himself a Libertarian that's never going
to be a game Cher and that's what we
need here is a game changer uh so do you
think that the new libertarian party is
poised to deliver a game Cher well I uh
I hope so um you know look it's with all
these things like that's what I try to
do right like I'm always like trying to
do that um I think that it was I think
the Mis kogus taking over the
libertarian party was necessary for
there to be a chance for the libertarian
party to do that we're still we're
fighting a very uphill battle like
anybody who believes in Liberty is
fighting an uphill battle um but perhaps
more uphill now that the me caucus is in
power well I I would completely disagree
I mean I think that look it doesn't
matter I mean like you know you could
say that um there's like big donors have
walked away from the libertarian party
since they came in which like several of
them have and that one in four members
have also walked away well okay yeah but
look I mean the truth is that there was
basically a civil war within the
libertarian party and no matter what
happened in Reno believe me if we if we
had lost in Reno we represented like 80%
of the party I mean like tons of people
would have walked away from the party
you know what I mean so that's the the
truth is that say when lockdowns came
the old libertarian party basically
rolled over and took it and didn't want
to say anything and in fact the only
comments they would make would be like
well we do think you should stay home
you know like mask mask social distance
or whatever so you the basically that we
already already deserved to if they're
not even going to try to stand up for
Liberty then I don't care if some big
donors will support you and are
alienated by us like and and again also
the Joe Jorgenson campaign I mean
there's like a total like embarrassment
that she didn't she was Joe Jorgenson
would go to uh give speeches where a
crowd full of people in masked were
forced to be socially distanced in a
park where a father had been arrested a
week earlier for having a catch with his
son and talk about
the drug war or how socialism is bad or
something like that and not even like
not even want to touch the moment that
she was living in so in terms of like
can the libertarian party spark like the
next Ron Paul movement well no not if
it's doing that it has no chance but
surely you believe in like like surely
you are relate to the place that I'm in
where I sort of you know have
consistently looked at the political
duopoly and I'm like nope I don't have
to vote for team blue and I don't have
to vote for [__] team red either and
now I look a little bit at the former
libertarian party and now the
libertarian party as taken over by the
me's caucus and I'm a little bit like no
I don't have to vote for the hash wear a
mask Joe jensson crew I don't have to
support them but I also don't have to
support the um what was it it was like
the weager genocide is fake and Ukraine
is gay hash fake and gay like I don't
know whether that was LP or LP and that
was but like surely like surely and I
don't mean to cherry pick but I do think
that that is somewhat representative of
like the edge lordy meing trolling of
the lp and the fact that they're trying
uh what they perceive to be an edgear
messaging strategy that I think frankly
just moves a lot of people further away
and so I'm looking at these two options
and I'm a little bit dissatisfied by
both because I'm like where's the actual
representation of people like us who I
think are pretty reasonable I think
pretty pissed off about the covid regime
pretty interested I think a lot of us I
think we share a lot of similar values
and I think we want to see libertarian
ideas win the day and be successful and
I'm not looking when I look at
Angel mcardell and Michael Heist and the
me's caucus takeover and Jeremy Kaufman
I don't really see champions for the
things that I value well all right so
first of all I I will say that like I
hate the Twitter Edge lording and [__]
posting and that stuff I just hate it I
hate all of it and I've I've been on
record I've been on record of this for
years I
strategy okay but you're separate no
there's one state affiliate in New
Hampshire where that is their that is
their entire thing and they've been
totally like basically at war with the
caucus like you know what I mean like
total and so it's not as if like
that's there are also by the way there
also are uh it's much much better much
much better um but there's also been
like on the other side like non-music
controlled you know State Affiliates
that do like a ton of this like kind of
just engagement farming kind of shock
value stuff and I just don't like it I
just don't like any of that like to me
like what I always said was like what
got people excited about libertarianism
to me was Ron Paul giving history
lessons like this stuff is just lame but
I will say that cuz I don't know where
you are that you know like the um the as
far as the weager genocide thing goes
the state department put out under
Donald Trump right they put out in in
his like last year that just this
announcement that there's a genocide
going on in China they the only source
that they quoted was that uh Zen guy
who's numbers were completely wrong and
so I I would certainly be like skeptical
of like listen I'm not get if you're
telling me a government's genociding
some people like I'm listening I hate
governments they do terrible things I me
to say the Chinese Communist party is
doing something bad well there's no
question they're doing something bad and
they're you know a brutal authoritarian
I think more fascistic really than
communist government um
but those Zen numbers and I believe he
even admitted them this it wasn't even
like a oh you have this interpretation
you have these like he didn't carry the
four when he was supposed to and made it
out like they're doing something that
they're not the way but but I think
there's a ton of space for people like
all of us scrupulous um truth Seekers to
look at the information that we
currently have some of which is
absolutely unreliable right uh because
it is very hard to figure out what goes
on within the CCP controlled borders I
think it's very fair to look at these
reports and try to assess out what is
true what is false which numbers are
inflated which reports we ought to
believe prop publica had a really good
investig some of the surveillance regime
um that's used to contr the weers in
Shong Province I think it's very fair to
like have those of conversations the way
to do that um is not to just be outright
denialist and then to hashtag fake and
gay right like this is obviously not
like I said I don't the the fake and
gate thing like I just I hate all that
stuff well I also look they'll say their
argument is like well look this blows up
this is the way to get a ton of
attention on Twitter and then they'll
see our other tweet that's like defend
the guard and like doing all this
serious stuff my thing is always like my
calculation is like I think you turn off
way more people than that than that
benefit is but I've made that very clear
privately to to those guys for years
I've done it publicly to them so look
I'm not saying like none of this is none
of this is perfect and I wish uh I wish
all Libertarians would just shut up and
do exactly what I tell them to do but it
turns out that's not how Libertarians
are wired so it doesn't it doesn't work
well so I mean in one sense it sounds
like what you're saying is you know
there was this awful messaging that
existed before this very out of touch
messaging during just one of the most
insane years in modern history and so
this new leadership came in they came in
pretty hot they've dialed it back a
little bit I looked into some of the
numbers coming into this some of these
were compiled by their the misus caucus
enemies the classical liberal caucus
which but what they compiled here is
that revenues are down historically when
you adjust for inflation and not only
big donors but monthly donors are down
and I looked into the actual reports
behind the numbers and it's all accurate
except the lp did not adjust for
inflation which seems like something you
should do well what do you mean raise
prices like um the raise the membership
they're showing re like in the lp
reports the revenue looks kind of like
slightly up because inflation
um but if you adjust for inflation
revenue is at historic lows yeah but so
what's the your take away from that my
take away is that revenues are down
monthly I mean that's like you know
that's like if you have a job where
you're making a 100 Grand a year and
then you just keep your job and
someone's looking at that and go like ah
dude your your income is way down from
there I mean yes that's true but that's
I mean if you're blaming the Federal
Reserve then I'm with you but if you're
blaming the mis's
caming the Federal Reserve and the Mis
okay we're we're saying technically I
mean usually when
organizations measure their historic
revenues they would adjust for inflation
that's not true if like Coca-Cola puts
out like earning statements they're not
going to adjust for inflation Coca-Cola
isn't going like they'd be like no we
took in three Bill we had three billion
this year 3.2 billion this year we'll
leave it for the audience to judge
whether that is a good or bad number but
uh what do you think is going on here
internally well I mean just to to be
clear like I'm not you know I have no
position in the libertarian party and
like if you talk to like Angela or
someone like that I'm sure she could
give you much better answer than this
I'm not like on the lnc I just I'm I
just do standup comedy and podcast about
this stuff but from what I I understand
about it there was they did have this
major problem with like this software
thing um I I don't exactly know the
details of it this is something that
started before the Mis kogus took over
and all through them where a big basic
disaster of transferring data so I think
that hurt him a little bit but
regardless of any of that um it's like
this I think that the the state of the
libertarian party was no matter what
happened at Reno going to it was going
to be a rebuilding you know like couple
of years in this sense that there's a
lot of people who were very turned off
by uh the mises caucus in the
libertarian party and there were a lot
more people who were you know what I
mean willing to go to to fight for them
and that's why we won um in terms of the
the stuff with donors uh walking away
again like I said it's just to me if the
if the calculation is going to be that
well like like let me say it like this
right there are kind of these storms
that come in where things are very
sensitive to talk about like right now
it's the Israel Palestine storm that
we're living in where it's like kind of
takes a little bit of courage to talk
about these things because you know
you're going to get this backlash the
storms end and then it's like no one
cares like I lab leak Theory any of us
worri worried about talking about that
now you worried about your YouTube
channel getting no it's fine you can
totally talk about it that was we were
in a storm a couple years ago where you
couldn't talk about that Ukraine is like
that right and for me Libertarians are
when we have value at the most is when
in those storms we're willing to stand
up and say the courageous thing this is
why Harry Brown writing uh uh when will
we learn on September 12 is like the
most amazing thing ever because the day
after 911 he had the courage to say that
the the only way this libertarian party
thing is ever going to work and grow is
if in those storms we have the courage
to say things now I'd agree with you but
that's on that could come without some
of this other stuff not help I want to
stop there though but that's not what
the mees caucus is doing I would say I
would argue they are how I mean that I'm
talking about every single one of these
uh conflicts so like the the Ukraine
storm when that came they were the first
ones standing up opposing that policy
right now in Israel doing the exact same
thing so like that's the type of thing
that I do think the mises caucus has
that they bring to the table is there
use in that if nobody takes them
seriously anymore right like like I
don't think that's true that nobody
takes them seriously anymore people
still take them seriously yeah I don't I
went from being like yeah maybe I'll
vote for the lp presidential candidate
to now it's like I would sooner vote for
anybody else available on my ticket than
these people why what what is their
crime that's worse than Joe Biden and
Donald Trump I mean I'm just I'm stunned
by the
shift toward I don't I don't believe if
you actually I think put any of these
people in power I'm not sure they would
know the first thing about what to do
with it or how to actually craft any
sort of policy I mean you have text
exchanges from Angela McArdle and
Michael Heist talking about how uh
personally bankrupt they are and how
much money they've lost in the process
of doing this I'm sorry but if you can't
run an extremely small just speaking
candidly here political party and you're
not able to you know keep your
supporters in any way what why would
anybody trust your competence overall
like I'm just very who are I mean who
are who's even running for president
this year right like like if if the but
if the idea is you know you are a
political party and you are putting
candidates up for you know election for
political office surely they should be
people in the room da Dave was going to
run for president and you didn't run for
president and
they're kind of flailing is that kind of
a I mean I think you're I think you're
kind of over playing this kind of like
no one takes them seriously and it's
it's like they text messages there were
those text messages I want com I don't
want to comment on private text messages
that people like put out there I I also
just think that's lame and wrong and
it's also like it's
not I bet I could find if I found
private text messages right like let's
say I just had access to all of your
texts with your wife and your text with
your husband I bet I could cherry-pick
them and and put him out there and be
like look their marriage is failing look
at this one exchange that I found talk
about how we're out of money yeah okay
well fair enough um but uh but I'm just
saying like you so I don't know like
you're telling me you got one exchange
these aren't messages between spouses
right and and I also I but they messages
between co-workers still they're
messaging between I I mean I don't know
even technically what you would call
them but the fact that in a moment
they're like complaining about something
I'm not going to like draw too much of a
conclusion from that I do think like
yeah like there's been the membership
and and and money is down the libert
Arian party historically has had lots of
different periods before where
membership and and revenue have been
down in fact they've had points where
Revenue was very down but membership was
very high they've had points where the
vote totals were the highest but the the
membership was very low there's been the
truth is that the libertarian party a
but also for the entire history they've
largely not been successful that's the
truth we took this thing over a couple
years ago and it's a huge restructuring
uh um you know that's been going on now
in terms of like me not running yeah
look I mean there there's definitely
something to that like I was considering
that that was kind of like a rallying
point for a lot of our guys and I
decided not to do it um and so there's
been some disappointment about that but
I do think that like I'm I'm hopeful
that over the next year and over the
next couple of years this is going to
like be I almost think of the misus
caucus as like it was like this
cleansing thing where we had to like
return to like radical principles that
are what the party was started on to
begin with and then kind of like now out
of that has to grow like candidates
because that's really what rallies
people that are radical principl
candidat I want to take this seriously
because I agree with you right like
there was a reason why I didn't choose
to like tweet and take a little gleeful
Victory lap about the you know text
message and email Revelations about all
the trouble that LP was in right like I
agree with you that it's important not
to draw overly broad conclusions about
that but say you wanted to take your
argument seriously and you wanted to
look for these small green shoots that
are poking up through the dirt as to the
ways in which which the me caucus
takeover has been successful where would
you tell us to look well like what what
should we look to as evidence of you
know actually it's pretty
good it's uh there there have been like
actual what the libertarian party always
kind of has only is that there have been
local elections that they've won and
that stuff does matter I mean there are
POS you know there are people where
we've gotten like on School boards and
on City councils and Mayors I think a
couple sheriffs you know what I mean
throughout the country again I'm not
like Heist is a better guy talk to about
all of this stuff to like rattle off all
the names they have launched this uh the
mises caucus has launched this project
decentralized Revolution thing which I
think is a really great um like template
for how the libertarian party should run
and it's very different than the way
it's been used before where kind of like
the strategy for the libertarian party
would be like um you know you show up to
like your state affiliate and they're
like what can I do and they're like I
run for something and whereas this is
now targeting like winnable elections
with nullification Powers so that's kind
of like the idea is building this thing
where the national is kind of like
messaging and then trying to funnel that
into like the local winnable elections
with nullification strategy of like the
sunrise movement I believe which is like
the organization that initially put a
bunch of money behind Alexandri Casio
Cortez okay right like like there's you
know a specific there's a big
infrastructure but they're going even
more local than that which is like I
mean he was saying sheriffs are a big
one because they've got a lot of power
and um or like a city council member or
something like that things that people
uh where you can nullify Federal uh um
laws or federal
mandates relatively low voter turnout so
you actually have a chance of winning
right so that's kind of the the plan and
then the the thing is that you know
again like I said the other thing to me
is just that it is like look there I'll
I'll take responsibility in some way
that a lot of my guys on Twitter are
like can you know can fly off the handle
and say some some wild [__] but the one
thing I will say about my guys is they
don't compromise on the libertarian
stuff and they're not going to be afraid
to like you know say the thing that will
get you a lot of backlash when it really
matters now I wish I'm like I said
before I'm not for a lot of the edge
lording stuff I don't like that that's
not how I run my Twitter I mean I'll
insult people sometimes if they insult
me first or stuff but I'm not like the
non-aggression principle apply to kind
of right my version of that like if
provoke I suppose I can be a little bit
vicious on there sometimes so I'm not
like saying I'm perfect in vicious to
anybody in this room about say RFK
Junior no just k i I think I think I
don't think I was that you honestly I
don't think you were either um it was
Michael malice who was vicious um oh
yeah well Michael malice is a a furious
woman you got to be careful about him on
Twitter no I mean it's all in good fun I
I'm also the type of person where I can
just take it like I don't care Twitter
also kind of does that to all of us you
know like it just it is this thing that
yeah it's just and it's hard not to like
get sucked into that but I don't think I
don't think like what I don't think that
I don't think I've gained like a
following in the libertarian inside of
things because of any of that I think
like people like like me because I'm
good at explaining this stuff and like
to me that's always that's the way
people are converted to you know like
people will bring up like that one time
Ron Paul was on uh uh Morton Downey Jr
and he kind of snapped at those people
but that's never anyone's origin story
no one ever goes I'm a Libertarian
because I saw Ron Paul on Morton Downey
Jr they go I saw him explain history to
Rudy Julian Dave I think you're un
possibly unintentionally making my
precise argument I am so so in favor of
being bold and aggressive and courageous
and Truth telling and saying that
unpopular thing at an important time I
mean I felt very riled up in the covid
days um and it sometimes felt like I was
maybe not at recent but like you know
one of the only people in my sort of
Social Circles very comfortable sticking
my neck out and being like no [__] no
you shouldn't be forcing me to show my
vaccination status at the door to enter
a New York City restaurant no how dare
you and to the extent that you are going
to force that everybody should Forge
them I'm sorry but like the liswell
forging services are open I'll do it for
the low low price of 0 right like we
need to be doing Mass Civil Disobedience
because this type of thing is just
profoundly authoritarian so like I am in
favor of all of that I in favor of that
sort of boldness but I don't see that in
what the lp post takeover is doing and
that's the thing that gives me pause I
mean it's interest your metaphor of it
being a CLE sort of cleansing fire or
something that that that's it's kind of
interesting I mean that's a way to think
about Trump as well even if
you're regardless how you feel about
trump it kind of cleared out the
Deadwood in the Republican party and you
know I don't think any of us are uh
saying that the libertarian party that
existed before was exactly uh tearing it
up or killing it I I I am I'm interested
in can I just can I just say though
because I think like to some degree it's
kind of like I think you might be a
little bit guilty of the same thing that
I think like the New Hampshire guys are
guilty of in being like no this is the
the strategy because this is how you get
a big F because the truth is that there
are 50 state Affiliates okay and a whole
bunch of them are just doing exactly
what you're saying you'd like to see
done but you're totally fixated on the
one because they're saying this wild
[__] even though everybody else
everybody at the top of the mises caucus
like leadership has totally called them
out for it and been like hey we think
this is stupid and unhelpful so I'm just
saying that like there's a ton of those
guys there's a ton of State part but I'm
not just talking about the lp New
Hampshire I'm not just talking about the
you know authors of the tweets uh at
like Megan McCain morning her father's
funeral like cry more pork chop I think
that was an LPN tweet not an LP National
one you know OB 100% was not an LP
National but but I I but I would say
that like you know the lp National has I
I see tons of TW you would think that
the lone political party that DS to
represent you know me and Zach that when
I would see these Tweets in my feed from
the lp national uh or organization when
I see these Tweets in my feet you would
think that I would be like oh yeah I
maybe roughly agree with that maybe it's
a little tonally different than what I
would go for but you know roughly right
idea in fact that is not the case I
think I unfollowed them because I'm like
this just makes me you know actively
feel ill I mean I I mean we can we can
you know go through and spend all day
doing this but I think that there's a
certain amount of I don't want to overly
fix it on the tweets right because
social media presence isn't you know
it's not like anybody really cares about
Twitter you know was bleeding
hemorrhaging users for a while there it
seems like it's had a little bit of a
Resurgence it's not just that I think
I'm also looking at the you know lack of
clarity regarding you know who they're
running for president um you know I'm
interested in these local elections but
I want to see better data as to almost
like fullon AB testing you know how many
people were winning office in those
types of Elections before the Takeover
versus now because that would be like
the pro proper methodology to use and
then it's a little more complicated than
that because you got to figure out like
which SP cuz like you know if you got 50
dog catchers that's not as good as one
Sheriff you know what I mean so it's
kind of like and also like some races
are winnable at a certain time and some
race might not have been it's hard to
all that out let me pull it back from
the party for a second because I think
we spent a good chunk of time there
talking about the libertarian party but
for Libertarians what do you think
Libertarians should be doing differently
to win and interpret that as broadly as
you want to sure um well I mean I like
I've said this for a long time but I
think that uh this isn't me this is
Murray rothbart uh so I'm not trying to
like take credit for coming up with this
um but that because there was kind of
like the battle between the hayekian
approach and the rothbardian approach up
that my definition of libertarianism was
straight off uh ripped off from HX
against monopolies well that in fact did
you you might have messaged me about
this uh once where I was talking about
the the split between the like win over
the intellectuals verse like verse like
the populist message so I'm a big
believer in the rothbardian kind of like
populist idea that and look I think you
see this with Javier Malay right like
this is the way it can be done like this
is the way to do it is to tap into these
this this kind of populist streak
particularly at a time when the elites
have so mismanaged everything and kind
of like talk to people about how they're
being ripped off like how they're being
ripped off and these guys are doing it
to you and then the the problem with
populism always is that it's completely
devout of any type of theory you know
what I mean like that's basically the
issue with the the new right in general
is like there's just no Theory it's just
everything they're against and so you
mean like the Holly Vance contingent
like those types or yeah I don't know
enough about him personally but I'm just
saying like a just trumpian movement in
general there's just no it's it's always
like he's railing against everything
that is pretty horrible and then he it's
like so what's your it's like good deals
make the best deals only me only I can
it's like there's nothing really there
but Libertarians already have that it's
like Libertarians have all the theory
but we're missing all of the like
populism to make it like appeal to to
people has almost pulled the greatest
trick because you're describing him as
somebody who really GRS this sort of
populist um messaging and and really
manages to you know use that to win an
election but he also I think represents
a little bit of an intellectual streak
too right like he has he has votes yeah
that's that's what I'm saying you should
have V hbd an Austrian Economist
yeah a economist he has the rth Barian
populism and sort of you know a bomb
throwing aspect to Hima wielding but
I've also seen like old TED talks of him
where he's doing you know like our world
in data chart showing you know the the
prosperity that capitalism brings like
he is uh a very interesting model I
think for Libertarians to look at I
don't know how much of it translates to
America or not but I mean I do think
look I think that if I were to say in
terms of like candidates like if that's
what we're talking about um whether in
the lp or not but like Ron Paul really
is who our blueprint should be I mean
and Ron Paul had a lot of things going
against him like I don't he's the
greatest living hero in America to me as
far as I'm concerned I'm just saying
that like you know he wasn't like the
best public speaker he wasn't like the
most like Charming guy he was older when
he really got very popular but he just
did he had a way of connecting you know
like it's like our our like
ideas knowing what's going on in the
world right now and then connecting it
to the average person of like how this
is screwing you over like and how this
is like this is the story of what
happened here so that to me is always
like my blueprint you know there's
different C if you the question was just
like my advice to Libertarians on how to
do libertarian um like I my thing is
always that it's like you have to
actually know what's happening in the
world and not just like live in your
theory I Libertarians are way too
removed just in theory and that's not
what anyone except us cares about like
and that's so you have you know it's
like that was the to me that was the
most impressive thing about Ron Paul was
that this guy was like a he was a
country Doctor Who Knew just knew more
and did not just knew the non-aggression
principle or not just knew like I've
read Hayak and rothbart but knew like
okay you know if you just sit Ron Paul
down and you're just like okay so tell
me the entire history of you know like
what happened the entire history of like
monetary policy and you know he could
just talk to you for three hours about
it because he just knows everything like
that's I think what much more you know
it's like I use my my father-in-law is
always like the gold standard to me of
Joe sixpack because he's just like he's
like a truck driver just been a truck
driver his whole life and he's just like
workingclass guy very smart guy but not
like you know not high fut and smart
like you know like regular gu and if I
start talking to him about the
non-aggression principle he's going to
look at me like what are you talking
about like who cares about this abstract
theory in your mind but talking to him
about how prices are so high like he's
very he's he's listening and then I'm
like okay well this is what happened and
this is why prices are so high and then
he's totally with me on that so I think
that's what Libertarians got to do is
like attach our Theory to the problems
that real people face and demonstrate
how we have solutions to them that's
what works this is I think why the um
obnoxious chorus of like belt weight
terion bugs me so much I think this is
so frequently thrown at reason but then
also I feel like I get a lot of like
weird personal insults about this um you
know to to to on Twitter and it's always
odd to me this idea of like what image
of you know me or Zach or Reason have
people concocted in their minds to
possibly think that we're you know
Beltway lobbyist shills in DC like like
or or you know overly policy wonky and
obsessed with these things I'm sorry but
like I spend most of my time I live in
Queens I moved away from Brooklyn
because I figured you know I've used
voice plenty time to do some exit and
it's time for a little bit of a a you
know child raising stage Queens pivot
because I'm a little sick of the
Brooklyn hipsters and now I spend so
much time around like Surfer Bros who
are the dumbest people you could
possibly find but the degree to which
they're so angry about like covid policy
and covid hysteria because it's so
frequently like forced them out of the
water and for any like outdoor athletes
this was I mean this is the thing that
gives them life uh and the fact that the
government could possibly crack down on
a solitary sport where you're Outdoors
you know separated from other people
it's just like an astonishing they're
not Libertarians because of huttin
policy ideas they're not Libertarians
because they read a KO white paper
they're Libertarians because they saw
firsthand that agree toage government
was going to Great Links during this
very difficult time to screw them over
and force them to step away from the
thing that they love doing that was
healthy for them uh and you see this in
you know Surfer communities and queens
and in Costa Rica and you know I
encountered some of these dudes in like
Portugal and like that's the drain
that's a that's a genre of person that
I'm so fascinated by and so excited
about and I hope the malaise of the
world can tap into people like that but
it's just like no they're irreverent
they're independent and a lot of the
times they haven't even thought about
how you know government is stepping on
their necks until it actually you know
becomes too impossible to avoid and I
don't think that they would ever put
themselves into you know the category of
libertarian but I think that there is a
deep libertarian Essence that gets
tapped into when you face any sort of
like authoritarianism from your
government yeah well I think you know
it's it's kind of an interesting Dynamic
but in terms of like the stuff you were
saying about like you know the people
the the Libertarians on Twitter who like
drag reason and stuff like that it's um
it's a non-specific complaint and I wish
they would actually communicate what it
is their I think you guys I think you
guys do for whatever reason I think you
inherit a lot of the KO hate um you know
what I mean like I
think deserves it a lot more than than
reason does send your complaints to KO
well I mean look KO totally like
humiliated themselves during Co and the
fact that they allowed some of that
stuff to be run under their name it's
like dude there's just there's kind of
no coming back from that like you can't
just you live in under a moment that is
the biggest Mass suspension of all basic
rights of a domestic population perhaps
in our history and you're going to sit
there and put out pieces that are like
the libertarian case for why this is all
all right and I mean so like so I think
they deserve it you're talking about
like the in favor of vaccine mandates
yeah in favor of vaccine mandates and
all stuff like that um and uh and then
and even some pieces that were like you
know under some libertarian Theory can
we justify lockdowns because would you
know it be an act of aggression if you
know just these mental gymnastics to
pretend that like what we all see is
going on here is not going on here and
then they were also wrong about
everything like on top of on top of
being wrong to try to justify this they
were just wrong on the information like
they would be saying like in the piece
where they did the libertarian case for
vaccine mandates they say in the piece
that it's become clear scientifically
that the vaccine uh um that the vaccine
gives you better immunity than natural
immunity which was like never none of
the science was ever even pointing to
that like it's just it's just on top of
just wrong on every level but I think
that like if you just the way you talk
about Co okay if that was all anybody uh
saw of you I can guarantee you you
wouldn't be getting push back from those
people and I think the core of it is
that was that a compliment in there
somewhere yeah you're great on Co yes
there's totally a but I think what you
get push back on at least from what I've
seen is the stuff that it comes down to
that Murray rothbart piece that it's do
you hate the state and yeah and that
when you what people don't like and I
think a lot of them um what gets a lot
of them worked up is that it's like when
you see the Libertarians kind of being
like uh taking this line that it's like
you know well they're just a bunch of
jokers who are really inefficient at how
they govern us and they've got these you
know they don't understand these
unintended consequences and these
buffoons can't get it right whereas like
this other cred of Libertarians are like
these people are monsters these people
are monsters who are destroying people's
lives and they're enriching their
friends to do it and they know what
they're doing and they're doing it
anyway and there's this kind of like
reaction against the people who take
more of the the unintended Jokers I
honestly think that both sides do in the
extremes do a bad analysis
on this on on looking at the motivations
of why government actors are doing what
they're doing I think that saying that
they're all a bunch of goofballs uh
which isn't my argument by yeah is that
that's not the right way uh but also
saying that people in government are
particularly nefarious or evil um I mean
I I subscribe to just basic public
Choice Theory where they're driven by
the same in that the of us are it's just
it's self-interest and self-image and
it's you know fouchi has bad incentives
that's why he does what he does not he's
an evil person I think it's so I think
it's well fouchy is it we can talk about
fouchy I I do think that you know what
Zach is tapping into is true to how I
look at it too I think it's frequently a
a mixture of malice and incompetence and
I think sometimes it's it's sometimes a
very case-by case thing where sometimes
it's more incompetence other times it's
more malice I would say with fouchi I
would probably uh you know say that that
airs more toward the side of malice but
I think that either explanation as
almost this it's like a reflexive tick
where it's like oh well State actors are
always malice and it's always you know
it's it's their evilness showing or the
other reflexive tick of well they're
never really corrupt um you know or evil
because they're always just dumb
incompetent buffoons like that shows
that you're not actually looking at the
facts of the case before you and to me
that indicates um you know a very
dogmatic way of looking at the world
that will lead you to bad conclusions so
I see it as frequently a mixture of the
so I certainly wouldn't say that there
it's like a 100% evil and that there is
no just kind of like buffoons there I
mean obviously there are tons of
buffoons in government but to your point
about like Hey look it's the same
incentives that drive all of us like
there there there's some truth to that
but that's almost like if there's like
you know uh some young man out there
who's like he's incentivized to want to
get laid so he like tries to charm a
girl and take her out on a date and then
there's another 25-year-old who rapes a
girl because you know what I mean like
they may have had the same incentives to
some degree but those are not like the
same type of people or that listen look
you can look at a lot of these examples
but if you by the way if you've ever
heard uh Hillary Clinton on tape
laughing about getting a child rapist
off when she knew he was guilty like
laughing about it like she just thinks
it's hilarious are you the Clinton kill
list do you think uh I I've done
everything I can uh to get there I don't
I don't think I'm closeing enough to to
but uh but like the like these people
and a lot of these people at the top
level of government are horrifically
evil people who will knowingly you know
like uh put in place a policy where
innocent people will die they'll lie
through their teeth to to sell the
policy their buddies will all get rich
off of it I mean like I don't think it's
like oh those are just like kind of the
same type of people as as a guy who runs
a bakery like they want more power and
he wants more power you know like yeah
they may want things but what some of
these people are willing to do to get it
is like so like crazy vicious and I do
think that at the at the top levels of
our government there it is permeated
with violent sociopaths who are very
comfortable doing very evil things and
look I mean even just like you look at
the um like when you step back and see
some of this and this is true in media
too like you know there's like uh was
that that woman from uh ABC who was
caught on the hot mic talking about how
she broke the jeffreyepstein story
one of the crazy things about that hot
mic is that what she's upset about if
you listen to her is not what you think
any normal person should be upset about
it's the lack of clout it's that she
didn't get the story she's like and I
had that's I the story that's just
journalist brain right like that's a
huge problem the entire not maybe not
the entire media class but a significant
a hefty portion of the media class is
obsessed with their own bloated and
frequently wrong sense of moral
superiority as well as this just
astonishing self-importance that God
made them journalists and they're God's
gift to man and it it but think about
how evil that is how evil it is that she
didn't quit you didn't quit and go break
this story anyway you just stayed there
what cuz the paycheck's good so you're
telling me you had a story about a child
rapist ring with the most powerful
people in the country implicated in this
story and your bosses for when now we're
not going to it'll mess up our
relationship with the royal family
that's what she says in the hot mic and
her response to that wasn't to quit and
just tell the story anyway like that's
that's insane and like so listen am I
judging her personally am I saying like
she's an evil I'm not saying she goes
home and kicks her dog in the face every
day but I'm saying what she is
participating in in her professional
life is something morally repugnant and
like that's how I feel about the highest
levels of government and media that
there there's just this Mass comp now
and by the way there's also I'm not
trying to get like all Alex Jones on you
here but like there is what do you think
about the atrazine in the water supply I
don't know any of that stuff
but uh I have read I think he was not
completely wrong about the frogs but
whatever uh that's a whole different
thing listen look Bohemian Grove is real
okay they do weird things there so I
don't know exactly what's going on with
these people and I don't like do the
conspirac some and I don't like to jump
down conspiracies that I can't prove but
it's it is totally reasonable to look at
like the Epstein thing to look at
Bohemian Grove to look at these things
and go yeah there's something going on
here that's pretty weird okay but my my
point Dave is that that if you are
looking at it as if this is because
we're all ruled by some satanic cabal
and I know that's not exactly what
you're saying but you're kind of saying
like Bohemian Grove they get together
it's wiing in that direction it's it's
the the problem with that if it's wrong
which I think that it kind of is is that
it supposes that the solution is to
clear out this corrupt class rep in what
I just said like what's wrong about what
I just said what's what what I'm saying
is it's structural it's not it's
primarily structural and where I think
you're right is that sometimes the Inc
you know Hayek even had an essay about
this why the worst get to the top and
it's like because the incentives of
power do tend to draw certain
personalities so you might even be right
that there's a disproportionate amount
of sociopaths or Psychopaths uh just
like there are in Corporate America
there's there's it's why there's so many
pedophiles who are are uh baseball
coaches or Little League coaches it's
why there there's so many you know like
uh abusive people who are cops because
these positions draw in those type of
people right I mean that's it's part of
the natural cycle of it but where I
think it gets um where the where the
populists um muddle this message is like
we have this uh you know shadowy class
of rulers that once we defeat them and
clear them out it's all going to be okay
but the reality is that it's the power
structure itself that the problem that
needs to be and I think but both can be
true at the same time right so like I
think both of those things are true I
think yes it's like power corrupts this
is you know what I mean like and that's
and that's a big part of it um and and
just like you said it's like this whole
thing this so I'm not like one of these
see this is what I think is so stupid
about the kind of like uh um I don't
know like the the kind of not altright
but like whatever that whole bigger
right-wing world is and their critique
of Libertarians is basically like no no
no we just got this bad group in right
now if we get them out then we can have
the government you know run for
Christians or whatever their plan is no
no this is stupid because it is like you
said it's inherent in the structure not
only stupid democ dangerous look the the
mix of democracy and big government look
at it obviously what what is it encour
what do it draw out of every politician
to say the most dumb down slogan to play
to the most uninformed voter to just say
the this is why Donald Trump did so well
because Donald Trump was like I'll do
you one better I'll talk like a
kindergartener and just say this I'll
just say everything's terrific or stupid
and and but really it's not as if any of
the others are much better than that
there was one speech that I was writing
about where he was talking about um how
you have to flush the toilet 10 to 15
times nowadays so lowf flow toilets he
was talking about how you have to run
your dishwasher like 15 times and at the
end of this uh whole rant he said
Housewives vote for me and I just love
that to like so many other politicians
it would be this like that would be
implicit and Donald Trump is smart
enough to just make it a [__]
explicit call to action Housewives vote
for me I critiqued the toilets I he's
run his own dishwasher in but it's also
like I you know it's it's total
exaggeration also I get where he's
talking about with like the dumb
environmentalist restrictions just make
everyday life a little bit worse in so
many ways and that's kind of what a lot
of the progressive left wants I'm sorry
but like I chafe every single time I get
like a paper bag in the grocery store
versus a [__] plastic bag because
it's just a matter of like why is it
that we're there's a huge contingent
that's just trying to make everyday life
a little bit worse and Donald Trump I
think very successfully tapped into that
yeah
100% but then so you're so you're G to
have this whole dynamic of like power
look by definition almost polit politics
is going to attract people who want to
rule over other people so that's already
that's what the magnet is there and then
of course it's the problem it's this mix
of big government and democracy which
are very related right so you have to
appeal to a a population who by again by
definition are only a very small
percentage of them are going to know
much about politics because that's true
about everything like that's true about
anything like that's true only a small
percentage of people have expertise in
any field right so then you have that
and then because the government's so big
there is so much power being wielded
that it's inevitably completely
corrupted I mean the what is our federal
government going to spend this year I
think over $6 trillion doll if you're if
you're spending $6 trillion do somebody
is going to be like actively lobbying to
get that power but Dave so this is uh
what this is the danger that I see in
the populist strategy is that this
rightwing that you mentioned um that it
does exist the the netcon or whatever we
want to call them that they just want to
install their version of a virtuous
leader to impose their vision of the
world and that is what that that's their
analysis is that that we have these
these um corrupt uh degenerates running
the government and we need you know good
virtuous uh Caesars or whatever running
the government and I worry sometimes
that the populist strategy in
libertarianism
is uh trying to cultivate that and it's
strengthening it and and this is like a
pattern you see throughout history is
the Socialists wreck things and then the
right-wing you know F fascist or
whatever you uh whatever form they take
then comes in and imposes right-wing
dictatorship or whatever and that unless
you
know Malay is a kind of interesting
example because he's he's coming in uh
on on to to fix what the Socialists have
done and the peronists have done um but
he's extremely explicit about who the
enemy yeah Ian we'll see again like by
the way we'll see how he does know if
he's the real deal
basically think you'rea right there kind
of TS to like this pattern that's played
out over and over again which is like
and you could see this um like where
there'd be these awful uh right-wing
movements as a response to Communism
like all throughout the world in the
20th century and look man like I I think
almost to me that's why you need this
libertarian populism even more because
that's one of the most important
components to put out this right-wing
fire because there is something really
dangerous there too like I mean I I
think about I was I remember saying this
on uh Rogan's podcast a few appearances
back where I was like I almost like you
know when you'll see these like the
craziest of the woke whatever the
craziest woke thing is you know they're
just like there we we're gon to convince
this three-year-old boy he's a girl or
like there's like um some you know like
drag queen giving a lap dance to like a
seven-year-old or something the lady
Rabbi on TV talking about the you know
Glory of Hamas but she had like a beard
yeah like there's whatever but you see
it and it's you're almost like it's like
my first thought is like whoa that's
really ins
and awful and then like your immediate
second thought is like oh my God we're
going to live under a right-wing
dictator cuz my God like what the
backlash to this is going to be and it's
usually not going to be some
right-winger who's like going to be like
well listen you have your right to be a
transgender person just maybe we
shouldn't push this on kids it's going
to be someone being like no you don't
have a right to do this and you know and
so the libertarian thing there is like
you got to kind of like try to to
harness that populist energy but in an
explicitly libertarian way talking about
that it's like no like the only answer
here and and this is kind of to me the
great libertarian Insight right cuz like
fundamentally we're kind of like a
compromise that's kind of like what
libertarianism is it's it's almost like
no call a truce like that's it like you
don't get to impose your view on them
and they don't get to impose their view
on you but you both get to do what you
want to do right like with your own
lives but that's kind of the thing that
the the the Insight is that it's like
that's actually also better for you like
in the long run you attempting to impose
your view on other people is going to
end up in them trying to do the same
thing to you and everybody loses the
thing that I would also add to that
though is that just because I I totally
agree with that articulation of what we
value as Libertarians the thing that I
would add to that though because there
is a little bit of tension within
libertarianism about thick versus thin
libertarianism and I would say you don't
have to be totally agnostic on all
cultural issues I think you can't be
well so the thing that I think about is
like you know so much of my politics
it's like the state ought to get out of
the way as much as humanly possible to
allow people to live their lives uh in
accordance with their values and what
they see fit but that doesn't mean that
I abdicate
you know my ability to have an opinion
about what the good life looks like and
what human flourishing is and what types
of choices people ideally ought to make
to be able to pursue that good life and
I think that this is sometimes where
Libertarians get a little bit um you
know binary where there's this idea of
like okay will you know some
Libertarians sort of gesture in the
direction of so much culture War stuff
and seem to have a very um almost very
narrow view of how people ought to live
and I'm not always super confident in
their uh reassurances that state power
should never be used to enforce those
ends and that that really gives me the
hgbs but then there are also a lot of
Libertarians out there who sort of act
like you're in some way a bad
libertarian or you Heir if you have any
opinions about what the good life looks
like and so I I'm interested in carving
out middle that's kind of on both sides
of the libertarian spectrum and what
I've noticed a lot of times on kind of
let's say on the left side of the
libertarian cultural space is that
they'll say that but also not recognize
that they're doing the exact same thing
like someone said to me uh once I gotten
this thing I got all the online uh
prostitutes mad at me um cuz I said that
uh we have our best performing episode
was with Aya our favorite rationalist
prostitutes so you know no I'm not
listen I'm just saying what someone said
to me I was just responding to someone
is where they said to me they go
Libertarians believe that uh sex work
should be legalized and normalized and I
was like legalized sure um not I don't
really agree with you on normalized um
because I like I actually don't think it
should be normalized or and you know
they said something like it should be
looked at as no different than being a
baker or being this I'm like well that's
never going to happen that and then he
goes oh see you're like you're you're a
Libertarian trying to fight a culture
War but I'm like but so are you you just
had the opposite opinion of me you
totally you totally made an extra
libertarian statement there by saying
that it should be normalized the only if
you want to be like look we're
Libertarians but we're also people so
what libertarianism has to say about it
is that it shouldn't be illegal that's
all libertarianism has to say about sex
work but as a person I could also sit
there be like well no I'm not going to
pretend that like if my daughter wanted
to go to college to become a surgeon or
wanted to be a prostitute I would have
like no feeling about that whatsoever
and that one wouldn't represent that I
have totally failed in the most
important job that I've ever undertaken
and the and that bad medical school
isn't that I'm just saying I'm allowed
to say that and now I can still say I
don't think the government should like
enforce this on anyone but what I'm
going to sit here and pretend that that
wouldn't represent a failure on my
that I wouldn't like like probably
murder to make sure that never happens
like I just I think what we I think what
we run into often at reason you tell me
if you agree is that people
interpret because we work at reason
they're like oh reason this writer or uh
video producer is putting out the
libertarian opinion on everything so you
know we have a bunch of different
writers who have bunch of different
opinions on social issues and sometimes
someone will write a column about
something and people will be like oh
reason is saying this us right and and
kind of to some degree it's fair too but
like it's totally fair for you to just
be like okay well the mises caucus took
over and look what this one account did
or look what this one guy did and then
kind of like think of that as the me and
that is by the way a lot of why you guys
get heat for that is because you are
kind of in some way married to the worst
of your things so when for a say which
by the way I'm not I'm not trying to
knock her I'm not or anything um because
again I don't know her at all but we had
like Twitter back and forth that weren't
good but when Elizabeth uh um Nolan
Nolan Brown tweets out a thing about how
the Ron Paul movement you know was like
all a bunch of racists coming into
libertarianism it's like okay so now I'm
in a position where I feel that I have
to like kind of battle you because I
can't just let someone who writes at
reason call My People a bunch of racists
when I'm like yo that's totally not true
and then now now now you know what I
mean it just becomes this thing where
it's kind of like and now you guys
fairly or unfairly carry that baggage
with you amongst that that part of the
movement that it's like well that's the
publication who has hires the lady who
says the thing the same way I carry the
baggage with
me Liz yeah since I'm the other blonde
Liz who now writes round up right I took
over for other uh no I mean the by the
way Liz n Bron is amazing journalism on
and by the way I'm sure I bet I bet I'd
agree with 80% of what she has to say
the thing that's so annoying about this
is like I don't know I'm an
individualist man I think it is
absolutely fair game to hold me
accountable for all of the work that I
have produced for recent TV and all the
work that I have written and all of the
dumb [__] that I have tweeted that has
come into my brain that I've just
thought the world needs to hear but I do
think that there is a little bit of a I
mean you're correct that we associate
you know sometimes our our ideological
opponents with you know the worst of
their crop but I do also think you know
we're Libertarians and we ought to be
IND idual at the end of the day and to
some degree it's like hold me
accountable for the things that I say
and believe and I'm willing to defend
I'm willing to go to the mat to defend
the things I believe but I can't sit
here and defend you know tweets of my
colleagues or tweets of other fellow
Travelers even if you know I tend to
generally like what they because I also
don't know what exactly was going
through their minds at that time and I
think that that's like a useful um you
know we should all probably carry some
amount of intellectual humility with us
and I think you know whenever the three
of us get into um the same environment
together or you know the two of us go on
a podcast together uh or the two of us
do a live stream together the thing that
is always really like stunning to me is
like there is a lot more that unites us
a lot more shared values than things
that um you know divide us and I think
let me ask you Dave about because we
have a couple questions to wrap up and
one pertains right to this this question
of turn making more people libertarian
or embracing libertarian ideas do you
think that most people at their core are
libertarian more libertarian or
authoritarian um you know I don't really
know what the answer to that is and I
don't I don't spend too much time
thinking about that what I know is that
I was totally compelled when these ideas
were introduced to me and that I know
that we're not at our ceiling you know
what I mean and that I know that I hear
all the time everywhere I go then I
travel a lot every single City I'm in in
every single town every single show
every single speaking event somebody
comes up to me and goes you're the
reason I'm a Libertarian like you
introduced me to this and then I found
this and then I found this and then it
all made so my thing is like I want to
make as many as possible or intro you
know not should make but you know what I
mean like it introduce them to this line
of thinking to as many people as I can
but I Al I never in my mind think like
oh we need to get 51% of the population
to be Libertarians because then we could
win some elections cuz the truth is that
um like nations are never moved by 51%
of the population they're moved by a a
small group of people who are dedicated
and like get their what they want to see
happen um so I think my thing is like I
think if Libertarians were I don't know
how many Libertarians you think there
are in the country right now I don't
know but if there's a couple million
maybe um way more than that how many do
you think I don't know I think I'm very
optimistic I think 60 70 80 million I
think people you think there are no but
I'm not saying like I'm not saying like
I don't mean like they they're a
Libertarian but they don't know it I
mean like they're a Libertarian and they
know it asarian I'm say let's say's
there's a few milon like could we get
that up to 20 million like that would be
that would change this country so much
and so like my thing is always just kind
of like whatever that number is look the
truth is if you talk to the average
person on the street you just we go stop
a random person right here and we go
what do you think of Ron Paul most of
them won't know who you're talking
about at best they'd think you're
talking about ran Paul and they
definitely would not be able to really
articulate and explain to you what the
libertarian position is we still there's
still so many people have just like
never come in contact with a lot of
these ideas so my thing is like let me
try to say it in the most compelling way
on the biggest platforms that I can get
on and try to get as many new people on
board as as we can like Ron Paul is that
that YouTuber who sells all the energy
drinks right that is that is bad uh the
related question that I have for all of
us actually not just Dave um
is what is your libertarian white
pill what's the thing that makes you the
most optimistic about okay well I'll say
things areed here let me uh let me give
the gene ebstein uh the gene ebstein
case for radical optimism which I always
love this just like speaks to my soul
but so this was his thing that he said
was he was like I hope I do it justice
but he was like okay if you were sitting
around in
1845 and you said uh to your buddy you
went you know I think in 20 years
slavery is going to be
abolished they'd be like you're out of
your mind like the slave trade is like
at the height right now like slavery is
R it's it's just been an institution for
all of human history like what in what
world could you imagine that in the next
20 years across the west and in the
United States of America there's just
not going to be slavery anymore but that
crazy guy would have been right I think
he does one for the Soviet Union too
like if you had been saying in the ' 80s
the Soviet Union was just going to be
gone within the next 15 years like
toally and so like it is not there are
moments like that where things that were
seen as like just inevitable
institutions are just gone and they
don't come back you know and so I would
say right now like look in the year 2002
and I remember you know I'm old me and
Zach are old you're not but now you're
at a point where I could go back 20
years and still I was an adult then um
but I remember the whole year of War
propaganda leading up to the war in Iraq
and like that was just it it didn't
matter if you got your news from Fox
News or the New York Times or MSNBC or
anything it was just unanimous you know
what I mean that it was like hey they
got these nuclear weapons they're
friends with the terrorists they helped
us do 911 we can't let them hand these
weapons off to the Terr you know the
weapons they don't have to the
terrorists who aren't their friends but
they sold the story and there was just
no one else like with I mean there were
other people but they didn't have like a
platform but now it's like you have Joe
Rogan and Tucker Carlson and then just
like a million different shows that have
there's shows you don't we don't even
know about that half a million followers
there's there's probably 50 shows that
we all don't know about with half a
million people watching that show all
the time and so much of that those
dissident voices are getting out there
now so I'm like I think for the first
time maybe in human history the Monopoly
of governments over the the you know
like um receiving of information has
been broken I think they're freaking out
about that quite a bit but I think this
is see this is an enormous white pel and
I just hate I also just hate pessimism I
hate it it's like the sorry I was going
to say this is more what I say on my sh
I was going to say it's the gayest thing
out there okay is pessimism uh you're
allowed to say that our so you will
probably get hate mail but I think I I
don't mean gay like being okay anyway uh
but it's just like you didn't say the
it's just I don't I just think there's
like no like I got little kids there's
no option for me to be a pessimist like
that's just not an option that's like
you know the I use this uh example some
sometimes but it's like an analogy or
whatever thought experiment but like
it's like if there were like five men
with guns trying to break into my house
because they want to kill my wife and
kids and I'm there with with a gun and I
just sit there and just be like I don't
know man there's like five of them and
there's only one of me I just I don't
really think I'm going to win you know
it's like what like I got a away kids I
don't have any option to feel that way I
right away start you know it's like okay
what are we doing all right get in the
addict I'm gonna snipe him off from here
I'm GNA you know I got a thing of
gasoline I'm gonna make a bomb real
quick or whatever you know but you're
trying something so it's like you don't
have an option to just like feel bad
about the f yeah I mean my my white pill
is very similar uh you know I made a at
the end of the decade I made a kind of
like what was the 2010s all about and it
was called the death of The Gatekeepers
that was when it all started and during
Co we saw them try to come back and they
certainly did I think what was revealed
uh in the Twitter files and all that
shows how close we were to having that
information landscape kind of captured
across all the major platforms and so
didn't happen though uh you know Elon
bot X he's calls himself a free speech
maximalist I don't think he is but he's
at least trying to do something
different there's also now technological
solutions uh you know I'm a big Noster
fan it's a distributed Network got a
documentary about Bitcoin mining uh that
I'm here in New York for and that's
that's another you know major white pill
is the the loss of control over money I
mean how much more libertarian like
could you get there so between speech
and money uh being uh uncontrollable at
this point I'm pretty optimistic I think
for me it's a little bit different um I
like the idea of like the disruption of
the information industry the disruption
of The Gatekeepers but I think for me
the thing that gives me the most
optimism about the future of
libertarianism is actually oddly enough
the dirt bag left I think we're
currently seeing this weird fracturing
of this sort of wokeness culture that I
think for a long time had really seized
people's hearts and imaginations and you
know at a I'm 27 a ton of people my age
were just like totally wrapped up in
this and there was a little bit of this
sense and I know this you know analogy
has really been used far too much but
the sense of like burn the witch and
looking for heresy and then trying to
Stamp Out heresy and trying to ruin
people's reputation and livelihoods to
the fullest extent possible in this
almost like as if your your heart was
just seized by this ferv this passion
for this you know new religion of
wokeness and I think the thing that
we're seeing that is so wonderful now is
people are realizing how many false
promises that religion uh you know gave
them uh they're realizing a lot of the
lies there they're realizing the degree
to which some of these mob Dynamics can
really turn on them and and you know if
you're in this constant pursuit of moral
Purity where it's not even clear what
these morals are based on boy have you
really uh been sold a false bill of
goods and landed yourself in a very
difficult situation um so I think the
irreverence of a lot of the dirt bag
left uh and the sort of people from
within the left who are willing to look
at their own side their own teammates
and say hey what you're doing is just
crazy and frequently they'll do so in
almost the terms that you're talking
about the ones that you know you use on
your podcast and sort of like this
boldness this irreverence um to some age
I think we're in a moment where like if
you would call the 2010s this era of you
know extreme um overwrought earnestness
I think to some degree the 2020s are
thus far the era of like there's
absurdism uh that's on the rise and I
think you see this a lot with jensy you
see this a lot with the dirt bag left
and I think that it's actually a really
good thing to be able to poke fun at um
you know so much of the [__] that
people were pedaling in your prior and I
think also to some degree as people get
older and like all of us have kids and
so you know whether you like it or not
we have skin in the game there's more at
stake there's a sense of I care what the
future looks like I care that my son has
a good life um and I think to some
degree you also see there was a lot not
just care but like care like more than
I've ever thought cared about anything
more about his life good my own life
good I would do anything to and I think
you know any parent feels the same way
but I think there's this sense of like
even if it took you know Millennials or
people of R ref generation a longer time
to get to that stage and maybe they did
that later they're doing it and I think
to some degree you see people who maybe
in their early 30s were obnoxious you
know Lefty activists who now are raising
kids and seeing kind of the error in
their ways and thinking oh actually I
suddenly value different things than
what I valued before and I think when
kids are taught things that parents
disagree with in public schools or maybe
even not things that parents disagree
with but things that aren't phonics and
aren't math instruction there's a
certain amount of like well an Awakening
that happens a sense of like what lies
was I believing and what lies you know
was I pedaling all along and I think I
think that we're seeing a lot of this
wokeness crumbling right now um and I'm
kind of delighted by it I look forward
to the ash sheep and hopefully people
will gravitate toward more freedom um
you know and sort of learn the
appropriate lessons from that I don't
know if they will it does seem uh it
seems to me like there's there's like um
there's several different layers of like
unsustainability with this country right
now like there's like the financial
level of like where you could just look
at like numbers on paper and be like
this can't keep going like I don't know
exact when
this yeah like like these entitlement
programs like just look at the numbers
on them this doesn't work and there does
seem to me be something about wokeism
that is just inherently uh you know like
this this can't continue like this it's
just like this might work for the four
years you're at college or whatever but
like how do you have a life afterward
with this and and it does seem to me
that one of the big like the one of the
big reasons why the the kind of not even
right Winger but the the anti-woke crowd
let's say is is winning in a lot of ways
is just because to to be woke is also it
seems to be miserable like you're just
you're sentenced to like a life of
constantly being miserable over this and
whereas like you know other people can
I'm not saying like I politically agree
with like uh the um like conservatives
but you're allowed to just like have a
family and be fairly happy and not like
you know be at war with every inch of
the world
it's a religion with no Absolution it's
a religion with no Redemption and I
think at a certain point people get a
little sick of that because it's a like
you said it's a miserable way to live
and I don't know I at my core I am a
huge Optimist and I think people
frequently try to do good and I think
people also frequently sort of yearn for
um a greater more robust sense of
morality than the weird version offered
to them by wokeism or wokeness and so I
sort of look at the degree to which some
of this is fracturing and splintering
and I begin to feel really good about it
I'm wondering you know how much more um
Dei bureaucracy will various Industries
have to deal with before we essentially
realize we're paying a ton of middle
managers and obscene amount of money and
like we actually and I think to some
degree these things are related right if
if we are thrown into harder Financial
Times whether in terms of um the amount
of money the Federal Reserve is printing
and the the amount of money the US
government is spending or you know a
recession to some degree you know paying
six figures to the DI bureaucrat that
you just hire doesn't make very much
sense uh and so a lot of this fat gets
trimmed I also think it's related to the
question of free speech and free
discourse because the ability when there
when that scale is tilted by moderation
that is being controlled by this
apparatus then it makes it harder for
just normal people to say that doesn't
make sense and I'm hoping that the the
discourse is getting loosened up now and
and that people can speak honestly and I
mean that that's partly what we want to
do with with the show and really
appreciate Dave coming to participate in
that today absolutely and we will be
back here next Thursday at 1 pm Eastern
and every Friday subscribe to the new
podcast feed uh subscribe to TV to get
new episodes and thanks for
watching thanks for listening to just
asking questions these conversations
appear on reason's YouTube channel and
Facebook page every Thursday and the
just asking questions podcast feed every
Friday subscribe wherever you get your
podcast and please rate and review the
show